On Monday we talked about
uplift and its various ways
one can interpret
uplift--and I know you had a
lot of that information in
the Tera Hunter reading,
but it's really one of these
sort of foundational issues
for this class I wanted to
sort of labor over for a
while.
Another foundational issue
is one of those keywords
talking about, I
talked about on Monday,
which is race management.
Essentially, that's
what this lecture today is
about. This is a
lecture looking at Booker T.
Washington, W.
E.
B.
Du Bois and the politics
of accommodation and
assimilation. It is a
debate that has manifested
itself in many
different forms,
in different voices
throughout so much of the
post-emancipation
African American experience,
and it's a debate
that's still with us today,
in ways that I'm pretty sure
will be coming back into
play on and off during the
rest of this term. So the
historian in me always wants
to contextualize. I want
you--and I'm not
crazy about dates,
but I want to give you a
timeline. It's important
for you to actually put
down in your notes. I'm not
putting up on the screen
cause it would be a one
slide show. It
wouldn't make any sense,
but understand this
timeline. Generally
speaking, at the
post-emancipation moment,
1866 forward, you have the
appearance of a range of Jim
Crow laws
separating the races.
I can't tell you a
specific start date,
because they vary by state.
But it's important to know
that they start
with miscegenation,
this fear over
black and white sex,
black male and white female
specifically. So there are
laws against miscegenation,
at first. Then there are
laws in some states about
separating the races as far
as education. "Now we're
going to actually have to
educate these black folks,
we can't educate them in the
same space." And then
within about a decade,
now we're talking mid-1870s,
the laws start appearing on
separating the races
in areas of public
accommodation,
transportation. And that's
really where most people
point to the start of most
Jim Crow laws, is around the
mid-1870s. That's the first
point in the timeline, the
mid-1870s. You already know
about Reconstruction,
the rise of Redemption,
of course. 1895 I pointed
to in the last lecture as
being a rather important
year. You have in 1895 the
National Baptist
Convention formed,
as I talked about on
Monday. You have in that
same year the great
leader of the race,
Frederick Douglass, dies.
A major political figure in
black and white America.
You have also in 1895 Booker
T.
Washington, the subject
of half of this lecture,
giving his famous Atlanta
Cotton Exposition Address.
So the National Baptist
Convention is formed,
Frederick
Douglass dies, Booker T.
Washington rises
in prominence,
all in the same year. 1896,
the National Association of
Colored Women is formed, a
group I canvassed in the
latter part of yes--of
Monday's lecture. The same
year, the Supreme Court
offers its decision in
Plessey v.
Ferguson. More on that in
today's lecture. In 1897,
the American Negro Academy
is formed and in 1898,
Alexander Crummell,
with whom I began Monday's
lecture, dies. So in
this three year window,
you have the
assertion of religious,
organizational, and secular
independence with the
National Baptist Convention,
the death of an icon,
Frederick Douglass, the rise
of another icon in Booker T.
Washington, the formation
of a women's political
organizing association
and social organization,
a very important
Supreme Court decision,
the founding of one of these
elitist attempts to solve
race problems, to
uplift the race,
and in 1898, the death
of one of those icons,
representing the leaders
in the Talented Tenth.
Undergirding all of that
are these Jim Crow laws.
So that's the context,
chronological context for
today's lecture. Let me
begin playing an excerpt.
It's scratchy, I know.
I'm just going
to play about,
I think about
forty-five seconds of it,
but it's also
kind of remarkable.
Booker T.
Washington: A ship lost at
sea for many days suddenly
sighted a friendly vessel.
From the mast of the
unfortunate vessel was seen
a signal, "Water,
water; we die of thirst!"
The answer from the friendly
vessel at once came back,
"Cast down your
bucket where you are."
A second time the
signal, "Water,
send us water!"
ran from the
distressed vessel,
and was answered, "Cast down
your bucket where you are."
And a third and fourth
signal for water was
answered, "Cast down
your bucket where you are."
The captain of the
distressed vessel,
at last heeding
the injunction,
cast down his bucket, and
it came up full of fresh,
sparkling water from the
mouth of the Amazon River.
To those of my race who
depend on bettering their
condition in a foreign land
or who underestimate the
importance of cultivating
friendly relations with the
southern white man, who is
their next-door neighbor,
I would say: "Cast down your
bucket where you are"-- cast
it down in making friends
in every manly way of the
people of all races by
whom we are surrounded.
Now that's--that's frankly
just show and tell. That's
Booker T. Washington,
reading from his famous
Cotton--Atlanta Cotton
Exposition address. I know
it's hard to hear, but I'm
going to go over it. And
it's also in the reading for
this week. But it really
is--we're entering a new
technological age for the
whole country, and sound
certainly is part of this
technological innovation.
And we'll be seeing more of
this as this
course goes along,
more sound files
and movie clips,
certainly. Now again, I
know it's in your reading,
but it's important that we
belabor part of the Cotton
Exposition address, because
it sets up--it lays down
sort of the political
foundation for so much of
the late nineteenth century
political philosophy. The
clip you just
heard, that's Booker T.
Washington saying, A ship
lost at sea for many days
suddenly sighted a
friendly vessel.
From the mast of the
unfortunate vessel was seen
a signal, "Water,
water; we die of thirst!"
The answer from the friendly
vessel at once came back,
"Cast down your
bucket where you are."
A second time the
signal, "Water,
water, send us water!"
ran up from the
distressed vessel,
and was answered, "Cast down
your bucket where you are."
And a third and fourth
signal for water was
answered, "Cast down
your bucket where you are."
The captain of the
distressed vessel,
at last heeding
the injunction,
cast down his bucket, and
it came up full of fresh,
sparkling water from the
mouth of the Amazon River.
To those of my race who
depend on bettering their
condition in a foreign land
or who underestimate the
importance of cultivating
friendly relations with the
southern white man, who is
their next-door neighbor,
I would say: "Cast down
your bucket where you are;
cast it down in making
friends in every manly way
of the people of all races
by whom we are surrounded.
Cast it down in
agriculture, mechanics,
in commerce, in
domestic service,
and in the professions.
And in this connection it
is well to bear in mind that
whatever other sins the
South may be called to bear,
when it comes to
business, pure and simple,
it is in the South that
the Negro is given a man's
chance in the
commercial world,
and in nothing is this
Exposition--and in nothing
is this Exposition is more
eloquent than in emphasizing
this chance.
Our greatest danger is
that in the great leap from
slavery to freedom we may
overlook the fact that the
masses of us are to live
by the productions of our
hands, and fail to keep in
mind that we shall prosper
in proportion as we are--as
we learn to dignify and
glorify common labour, and
put brains and skill into
the common occupations of
life. No race can prosper
till it learns that there is
as much dignity in tilling a
field as in writing a poem.
It is at the bottom
of life we must begin,
and not at the top.
Nor should we permit our
grievances to overshadow our
opportunities. To those of
the white race who look to
the incoming of those of
foreign birth and strange
tongue and habits for the
prosperity of the South,
were I permitted I would
repeat what I say to my own
race, "Cast down your
bucket where you are."
Cast it down among the eight
millions of Negroes whose
habits you know, whose
fidelity and love you have
tested in days when to have
proved treacherous meant the
ruins of your firesides.
Cast down your bucket
among these people who have,
without strikes
and labor wars,
tilled your fields,
cleared your forests,
builded your
railroads and cities,
and brought forth treasures
from the bowels of the
earth, and helped make
possible this magnificent
representation of the
progress of the South.
Casting down your
bucket among my people,
helping and encouraging them
as you are doing on these
grounds, and to educate--and
to education of head,
hand, and heart, you will
find that they will buy your
surplus land, make blossom
the waste places of your
fields, and run
your factories.
While doing this, you
can be sure in the future,
as in the past, that you
and your families will be
surrounded by
the most patient,
faithful, law-abiding, and
unresentful people that the
world has ever seen.
As we have proved our
loyalty to you in the past,
in nursing your children,
watching by the sick-bed of
your mothers and fathers,
and often following them
with tear-dimmed
eyes to their graves,
so in the future,
in our humble way,
we shall stand by you with a
devotion that no foreigner
can approach, ready
to lay down our lives,
if need be, in
defense of yours,
interlacing our
industrial, commercial,
civil, and religious life
with yours in a way that
shall make the
interests of both races one.
In all things that are
purely social we can be as
separate as the fingers,
yet one as the hand in all
things essential
to mutual progress.
The wisest of my race
understand that the
agitation of questions
of social equality is the
extremest folly, and that
progress in the enjoyment of
all the privileges that
will come to us must be the
result of severe and
constant struggle rather
than of artificial forcing.
No race that has anything
to contribute to the modern
world--to the markets of the
world is long in any degree
ostracized.
It is important and right
that all privileges of the
law be ours, but it is
vastly more important that
we be prepared for
the exercise of these
privileges.
The opportunity to earn a
dollar in a factory just now
is worth infinitely more
than the opportunity to
spend a dollar in
an opera house.
Three excerpts from
this critical speech,
1895. The clip I played and
the excerpt I began reading
revolves around the phrase
"cast down your bucket."
It's a compelling
story, a ship lost at sea,
not realizing it's at the
mouth of the Amazon River,
thinking it's going to die,
and safety was all around
it. Washington is
telling the members of the
Atlanta--Atlanta
Cotton Exposition,
gathering of
business leaders,
trying to raise
money to save the South,
or improve the South
in economic terms.
Washington's telling them
that they need to trust
blacks to do the right
thing. He's telling the
white industrialists,
the agricultural leaders,
you know, "You're trying
to import immigrant labor.
Don't do it. There's a
not a tradition of labor
organizing,
union organizing,
and strikes among blacks."
That's because they weren't
allowed in unions. That's
another issue of course.
But Washington's telling
the white owners of the
factories, and the
mills, and the fields,
"This is a
workforce you can trust,
who's toiled by you, who's
nurtured you and nursed you,
and we'll be
faithful. We've proved our
faithfulness in the
past." So it's a nativist
argument. "We don't want
foreign labor in here."
It's also an argument about
race management. He begins
by telling blacks, "Look,
you can't agitate. You need
to recognize that
this is our home,
the South, and the rural
South. This is where we are
and this where we need to
make our futures. And with
patience, and with time,
as we prove our fidelity,
we'll be able to demonstrate
that we are worthy of buying
that land,
tilling our own fields,
becoming economically
independent." As he says
himself, "The wisest among
our race understand that the
agitation of questions
of social equality is the
extremest folly." It's a
take it slow approach.
Now--oh one other very
important phrase to know
from the Atlanta Cotton
Exposition address is this
sentence: "That in all
things that are purely
social, we can be as
separate as the fingers;
yet one is the hand on all
things essential to mutual
progress." Critically
important sentence,
and you'll start to see
why. This is 1895. The
next year, the Supreme Court
hands down its--hands down
its decision in Plessey v.
Ferguson. The
majority of the court,
in an eight to one decision,
holds the following: We
consider the underlying
fallacy of the plaintiff's
argument to consist in the
assumption that the enforced
separation of the races
stamps the colored race with
a badge of inferiority.
If this be so, it is not by
reason of anything found in
the act, but solely because
the colored race chooses to
put that construction on it.
The majority is
saying--claiming that
separation of the races
stamps the colored race with
a badge of inferiority, is
all in the colored race's
head. Badge of
inferiority. The dissent
written by--well he's
the only person writing
it--Justice John
Harlan, says that ...
the arbitrary separation of
the citizens on the basis of
race, while they're
on a public highway,
is a badge of servitude,
wholly inconsistent with the
civil freedom and the
equality before the law
established by
the Constitution.
The majority is saying
the badge of inferiority is
nonexistent. It's a
construction. It's in their
minds. And Harlan says
exactly the opposite. It is
a badge of servitude to
force the separation of the
races in public
accommodations. Now what
was Plessey? What was this
case about? Many of you
know, I'm sure, the
outlines of it. June 7th,
1892, Homer Plessey, a U.S.
citizen,
resident of Louisiana,
buys a first class rail
ticket. He boards the train
and takes a seat in the
first class coach. It's a
whites only coach. You
wouldn't be surprised,
I imagine, he's asked to
move. Conductor understands
that he's not white.
And Plessey refuses and is
thrown off the train and
thrown into jail. He's
broken the Jim Crow laws of
segregation of the races in
Louisiana, the statute
established in 1890. Homer
Plessey argued that such
segregation violated the
Thirteenth and
Fourteenth Amendments of the
Constitution. The Supreme
Court said in response,
three years later, that
racial separation did not
abridge the privileges
or immunities of U.S.
citizens, or deprive persons
of liberty or property
without the due
process of the laws,
you know, the tenets of the
Thirteenth and Fourteenth
Amendment. The Supreme
Court says it doesn't do any
of these things, separating
the races. There's still
due process.
You still have rights as
a citizen. Now Plessey,
it's worth knowing, was
convinced he would win this
case. He actually pursued
the legal crisis in the
first place. He didn't just
walk up to the ticket booth
thinking, "I'm going to buy
a first class rail ticket
and have a nice
quiet ride," you know,
"to my destination." He
knew the law. He thought it
was wrong, and so he
decided to test it,
and he thought he would
win. And Plessey really
also thought that he
would win it because his own
literal embodiment would
prove how absurd segregation
practices and laws really
were. Going by the very
clumsy and messy sort of
dividing one's up one's
blood by races, Plessey
was seventh--seven-eighths
white, and was
so fair skinned,
he could easily pass
for white. In fact,
he had to confirm
with the conductors,
"Yeah, I'm black."
The law of the land is,
if you had just one, quote,
"drop of black blood" you
were black. So Plessey
ostensibly is a white man,
ostensibly, has
black heritage,
so he is black
legally. Would only,
you know, only by declaring
his race would people
realize that he was breaking
a law in the first place.
He says, "The
law is ridiculous,
and I'm going to test it,
and I'm going to win it."
Well, he misjudged the
justices. So you have,
starting in 1866 but
speeding up and going from
miscegenation to
education to transportation,
generally speaking, a range
of Jim Crow laws separating
the races. When Plessey v.
Ferguson is decided,
announced in 1895,
separate but equal is
established as in line with
the Constitution, and it
will remain the law until
Brown v.
Board of Education's passed,
ah passed? Declared in
185--1954. So we're talking
about almost sixty years of
constitutionally
supported federal law,
and then state laws,
established with Plessey v.
Ferguson.
Now the Supreme Court
offers its decision in 1896,
but the case had been in
process since 1892. Why
does this matter? I mean we
all know these things take a
while to bubble up to the
Supreme Court. It matters
because there's no
doubt that when Booker T.
Washington rose to speak at
the Atlanta--Atlanta Cotton
Exposition in 1895, he knew
that efforts were underway
to challenge racial
separation. Washington,
however, openly and famously
accommodated to white
southern and northern
business interests. This
was not a little quiet case
kind of trickling its way up
through the system.
Washington was a well
educated man. He knew
about race politics,
of course. And so he made a
conscious decision in 1895
to declare that he's on the
side of southern business
interests and
northern business interests,
separating the races to
reduce racial anxiety of
these whites. He
knew that Plessey v.
Ferguson was being fleshed
out--fleshed out in the
legal system. So when
you take these two moments
together, Washington's
speech and Plessey,
you can see that for many,
this embodies sort of the
low point that I referenced
in Monday's lecture,
the low point of the
post-emancipation African
American experience,
certainly in the realm of
political
rights, equal rights,
full citizenship rights.
Now it's pretty easy to
launch into an extended
critique of Washington,
especially in light of the
context of the era when he's
giving this famous speech.
But let me give you a bit of
biography and put us in his
shoes in a bit to see his
world view, and see where we
end up. Washington is born
in 1856. He's born a
slave. He worked as a
child, before emancipation
and after emancipation. He
knew--his life was a life
of work. He's out in the
coalfields in West Virginia
and then finds out about
this school, this
college, called the Hampton
Institute, in the far
east coast of Virginia,
and he decides this
is the place for him.
And so he literally works
his way there via odd jobs.
He has no money, so he's
working odd jobs to get some
more money to--to find a
way to get to the next way
station, before he
finds himself in Hampton,
Virginia, at the Institute.
And he's working odd jobs
there, while in school.
And at the end of the term,
at the end of
the school year,
he worked his way back home,
literally working his way
back home.
Through his labor
and his intellect,
he becomes the school's--the
protégé of the school's
principal. Hampton,
it's important to know,
was an institute dedicated
to vocational education.
That was the rationale
of the Hampton--Hampton
Institute. Learning crafts
and skills was critical.
This is about how to become
a better manager of crops,
how to become an expert
cabinetmaker. It was about
trying to develop technical
expertise in agricultural
endeavors, for
instance. The idea of,
you know, high
culture, elite refinement,
these things
could wait. In 1881,
Washington is
twenty-one--twenty-five
years old, and with the
support of his mentor at the
Hampton Institute,
establishes his own
institute, called the
Tuskegee Institute. Now
Hampton and Tuskegee are
still around today. They
are very different than they
were before--they were at
this, this era. We're
talking about the founding
moments. So Washington
establishes the Tuskegee
Institute, in
Tuskegee, Alabama,
and it's really quite
remarkable. He's--he's
establishing something at
the heart of white farming
land in Alabama. And
what you see in establishing
Tuskegee is Washington's
incredible skills at
building coalitions, at not
appearing threatening to a
white elite, or even
white small farmers,
yeoman farmers. He starts
buying up land for this
institute. He--he
gets his first students,
and they start building,
literally building,
this institute.
And eventually,
Tuskegee, the institute,
becomes the life blood of
Tuskegee, the community. It
becomes the economic engine
of this town. And this is
in a way a manifestation of
Booker T.
Washington's long term
strategy. I'm not saying
Tuskegee was a racial oasis,
or that blacks were fully
integrated, but
through Washington's model,
he economically integrated
blacks into Tuskegee,
the town. And this is his
long-term plan. Eventually,
blacks will get
their full rights,
but they do it
through long, slow,
hard work, through labor,
and becomes--by becoming so
economically vital
to wherever they are,
one could not help but
strive to incorporate them
in society. This
very go-slow approach,
Washington's great skills
at interacting with and
negotiating with
white business leaders,
results in he
becoming the darling of the
philanthropists and starts
getting money thrown at him,
by especially
northern business interests,
allowing him to build
up Tuskegee further,
and allowing him over the
course of the next twenty or
so years, to build
up--especially after 1895,
the last twenty years of his
life--he dies in 1915--to
build up a set of--a
portfolio of power that
leaves one with no other
conclusion to draw except he
was the most powerful
black person in the country,
undisputed leader of the
race. If a newspaper didn't
like his ideology
and ran editorials,
he would buy the newspaper
and fire the editors,
put his own
editors in place,
kind of like
Rupert--Rupert Murdoch,
right?
I mean he was a sort of
mogul in black America. An
advisor to President
Teddy--Teddy Roosevelt,
much to the great anger and
fear of many people in white
America. Now time to ask
some critical questions. On
one side, you can
ask the question,
well why did philanthropists
chip in? Was it because of
his charm? Well, I mean,
these were businessmen.
They--they had their
interests at heart here.
They saw that Washington was
training a fantastic worker
base. He'd follow
the Washington model,
very smart workers, trained
in certain skills and
crafts, ideal
for their mills,
factories, and such.
And he's also training a
permanent second
class citizen,
so this will be a docile
workforce. That's exactly
what the factory owners
want. A smart workforce is
not going to raise any
problems. Now asking a
question from the
other side--I mean,
it's so easy to sort of
condemn Washington for all
these different--these
reasons I've outlined just
now, but let's think
about where he was living,
what he was advocating.
What really was possible in
the Deep South in the late
nineteenth century?
We already talked about
lynching, rise of all kinds
of laws to wipe out the
black vote. The black vote
is disappearing radically
during this period in
the very last years of the
nineteenth century.
Seventy-five percent of
blacks still lived in
the Confederate South,
and the great majority
of that percentage were
agricultural workers.
Blacks were on the farms.
Half of the total southern
population was black,
but blacks owned just over
ten percent of the farms.
There was essentially no
agricultural education--I
mean the Tuskeegees are--the
Tuskegee kinds of model are
the exceptions--and black
farm production is low.
So you have a population
that is an aggrieved
population
politically, socially,
economically, with
very limited mobility,
almost no mobility,
living in a--in a state,
one could make the argument,
of terror. So when you
think about the lived
conditions of African
Americans, the
great majority of them,
what were the alternatives,
except for try to find a way
to develop
economic independence,
and then in time
become recognized as fully
participating in the--in the
citizenship rights of the
United States. What
might have been a logical
alternative? Well, the
alternative to Washington
and his accommodationist
politics is embodied in W.
E.
B.
Du Bois. Now it's important
to remember that Anna Julia
Cooper joined
the debate first,
arguing in A
Voice from the South,
published in 1892, that
the race would be saved by
investing in higher
education. This comes a
full decade before Du Bois
steps up to the plate and
challenges Washington.
But the fact is,
for better and for
worse, the debate has been
crystallized into a Du
Bois-Washington debate.
Certainly Washington
because he was so powerful,
and also certainly Du
Bois, partly because gender
dynamics and our
national culture,
of course, but because the
man plays central roles in
many different
moments of articulating,
shifting black politics over
the course of the next sixty
years. Du Bois's
response to Washington was
straightforward.
He referred to the
Atlanta--Atlanta Cotton
Exposition address as the
Atlanta Compromise. And
he said in his very famous
critique of Washington,
and I quote here,
that, "manly self respect
is worth more than lands and
houses, and that a people
who voluntarily surrender
such respect, or
cease striving for it,
are not worth civilizing."
Manly self respect is the
most important thing. It's
more important than
lands and houses,
and if you don't have the
courage to stand up to the
system that's fighting,
that's pushing you down,
you're not worth
civilizing. Now this
phrasing here is
rather important,
harkening back to the last
two lectures: manliness and
civilization. Du Bois
embodies this very elitist,
Eurocentric world view that
supports a manly ideal and
thinks it's the--it's the
really--it's the real goal
to demonstrate one's
capacity to act in a
civilized fashion,
to be civilized,
if you're really
going to have a chance at
entertaining full
citizenship rights. Du Bois
challenged Washington's call
for blacks to give up their
political power, their
insistence on civil rights,
and their desire for the
higher education of black
youth. Du Bois advocated
that the Talented Tenth,
this idea he developed
from Henry Morehouse,
advocated the Talented Tenth
be educated at the finest
institutions in
order to save the race.
Now why is Du Bois so
invested in this agenda?
Mainly because it reflected
a large part of his own life
experience, and a glance
at his biography makes this
much clearer. Du Bois
was born in 1868 in Great
Barrington, Massachusetts,
just about an hour and a
half--about an hour and
a half from here. It is
beginning to be
recognized actually,
in Great Barrington for
being one of its more famous
sons, as the phrase might
be. He goes to college in
the South at Fisk University
in Nashville and he gets his
Ph.
D.
at Harvard in 1895,
again, that important year,
after having studied for
some time at Berlin. He
publishes the
groundbreaking--groundbreaki
ng sociological study called
The Philadelphia Negro in
1898, I believe, essentially
creating the field of urban
sociology in the process,
and he helps establish the
America Negro Academy.
So just in this--in the
moment when Booker T.
Washington's rising up,
and bursts onto the national
scene with his Atlanta
Cotton Exposition address,
Du Bois is getting the
finest education in the
world, quite
literally, gets his Ph.
D., the very first
generation of African
Americans to
get that degree,
establishes the field
of urban sociology,
helps establish the
American Negro Academy,
and then starts an academic
career for the very first
phase of his life, teaching
at Atlanta University. So
Du Bois espouses and
embodies the value of higher
education and the role that
the black intellectual would
play in the salvation of the
race. He was at the time
one of the most
educated--highly educated
people in the world, and he
had a very full sense of his
own talent--the man had
an ego bigger than this
room--and his sense of value
to the world. He really
believed that politically
and intellectually engaged
scholars were the very
best--very best people to
interpret the white
European world. Again,
that idea, sort of
that's where the seat of
civilization is. And
you can see this belief
manifested or in the pages
of what people regard as Du
Bois's great classic, The
Souls of Black Folk. How
many of you have read The
Souls of Black Folk? Just a
handful, well
more than a handful.
About okay about
a sixth of you,
fifth of you, sixth of you.
Or read in it? Maybe more
hands would go up.
It's really amazing,
because when I
started grad school,
I went to grad school here,
I was introduced to Du Bois
and The Souls of Black Folk
in the spring of my first
year in grad school.
He wasn't part of the
undergraduate curriculum,
except in just a few kind of
strange places. Now it's
the undergraduate curriculum
like crazy, and I understand
it's even being taught in
some high schools. I mean
this is a radical change in
just twenty years, in terms
of Du Bois being brought
back into our national
narrative. Now The Souls of
Black Folk¸ you have an
excerpt from it in the
Marable and Mullings
reader. I'm not going to
belabor the history of
that early remarkable book,
but I do want to focus
on one quick passage,
really about the most cited
passage of the entire book.
And it's--it's a passage
that refers to the conundrum
of double-consciousness.
In Souls of Black Folk,
Du Bois recounts his youth
growing up in a diverse
community where he never
felt the sting of race until
his adolescence, this very
famous moment when he was--
his Valentine's Day card
that he was giving to a
young woman was refused.
He wrote about this dawning
awareness of the
racial differences in his
community, and his own
physical appearance,
and he said that this
awareness amounted to,
or he equated it to, a veil
that separated the races.
And he writes: ...
the Negro is sort
of a seventh son,
born with a veil, and gifted
with second-sight in this
American world, a world
which yields him no true
self-consciousness, but only
lets him see himself through
the revelation of
the other world.
It is a peculiar
sensation, this
double-conscious--consciousn
ess,
this sense of always looking
to one's self through the
eyes of others, of measuring
one's soul by the tape of a
world that looks
through the--excuse me,
I skipped a line here-- It
is a peculiar sensation,
this double--consciousness,
this sense of always looking
to one's self through
the eyes of others,
of measuring one's soul by
the tape of a world that
looks on in amused
contempt and pity.
One ever feels his
twoness: an American,
a Negro; two
souls, two thoughts,
two unreconciled strivings;
two warring ideals in one
dark body, whose dogged
strength alone keeps it from
being torn asunder.
A veil separating the
races. The passage is
important for the way in
which Du Bois describes the
differences in perspective
between white and black
worlds. As Ralph Ellison
would mention some forty or
fifty years
later in his book,
the differences that
rendered blacks invisible to
white America. I'm
referencing Ellison's
classic The Invisible
Man here. Du Bois says,
it is as if this veil keeps
blacks hidden from view.
But veils, as we know, allow
the wearer to see the world
outside. This is black
America's special gift,
according to Du Bois, that
they can see America from a
perspective that was all but
invisible to whites. This
gift, however, was also
a curse. It kept blacks
removed from the daily
commerce of culture,
society,
politics, economics,
so forth. Now why do I
linger on this point?
I linger on it because it
gets to the heart of the
problem that Du Bois felt
that black scholars like
himself had to deal with.
They were best positioned to
solve these problems, and
yet they couldn't be heard
and couldn't be seen
by the white world,
but they were in the best
position to interpret those
worlds to each
other. And in this way,
Washington and Du Bois are
actually quite alike. They
both sought to be
interpreters of the black
experience to white
America. They both sought
in some ways to control
the means of access of each
racial cohort to the other.
In the long run, many of
their goals were the same.
The means, however, were
profoundly different. It's
important to say here
that Washington was a rather
complicated figure.
Washington was very publicly
in support of the
separation of the races,
accommodating to northern
white business interests.
As I mentioned before, he
owned all these newspapers,
would control them if
they said anything bad about
him. But he also funneled
money to Du Bois and other
activists, knowing that
public support would destroy
him but
recognizing that sometimes,
not all the
time, but sometimes,
their points had merit. So
he would actually give Du
Bois--who had no kind of
resource like that--give Du
Bois through third parties
resources to continue the
battle. But in the
arena of public engagement,
public political engagement,
these two could not have
been more different. You
can see this in high relief
when in 1905, two years
after Souls of Black Folk
was published, when Du Bois
and other college-educated
black professionals meet at
Niagara Falls. Now they're
meeting on the
Canadian side,
not the New York side,
which they intended to do,
since the New York side
refused them lodging. But
these black, educated black
men and a few women--Ida B.
Wells was one of them--come
together to form an
organization that
is dedicated to full
citizenship rights for black
America. The so called
Niagara Movement demanded a
number of things: freedom of
speech and full citizenship,
manhood suffrage,
the abolition of all
distinctions based on race,
the recognition of
basic principles of human
fellowship, respect for
the working person. I went
through that quickly.
It's in the reader,
the manifesto, the Niagara
Movement's call to arms.
But it's important
to--we'll look back at that,
and think of these themes
that it's talked about.
Full citizenship
rights, the vote,
abolition of
distinctions based on race,
human fellowship, respect
for the working person. I
want you to think back to
this moment in six or seven
weeks--well, in about three
or four weeks then six or
seven weeks--this is an
abiding theme of political
organizing in black America
throughout much of the
twentieth century.
Washington was invited to
join the Niagara Movement.
He was by far the most
powerful black person in
the country. He was invited
mainly out of courtesy
because of his power. He
declines. Some of his
greatest enemies are the
people organizing
the Niagara movement,
but at least they had to put
out that olive branch. But
again, Washington knew he
would lose his white support
base if he made that move.
The Niagara Movement meets
annually until
1909. That year,
some members of the group
were invited to a national
conference on contemporary
race relations and the
struggle for civil
rights. This group of white
activists, many of them
with abolitionist roots,
back to the
previous century,
came together because of a
race riot and a lynching.
Heretofore popularly felt
to be a southern phenomenon,
despite like the New York
City draft riots as evidence
to the contrary, this race
riot and lynching happened
in Springfield, Illinois
in 1908. The riots were
horrific in their
material significance,
certainly, loss of
life and property,
but the symbolic
significance was far
greater, at least for
these organizers. The riot
occurred on the
hundredth anniversary of
Lincoln's--Abraham
Lincoln's birth,
and several black citizens
in Springfield are lynched
within a few blocks of
Lincoln's home and within
two miles of his gravesite.
Now the riot started when a
white woman accused a black
worker of raping her and
assaulting her.
She later recanted,
admitting that her white
boyfriend had beat her,
but it was too late.
Angry mobs formed and
started--started
looking for the perpetrator,
who was spirited out of town
quickly. But the mobs start
forming and attacking blacks
under the impression that
they were the ones harboring
the rapist. That the Great
Emancipator's memory could
be so sullied horrified
these whites--these
white liberals,
some of whom organized
this conference and invited
members of the Niagara
Movement. Together,
these white liberals and
a few representatives,
these black liberals
from the Niagara Movement,
decide to form a new social
betterment organization that
would be dedicated to the
pursuit of civil rights for
blacks, and that
organization is the National
Association for the
Advancement of Colored
people, the
NAACP. Du Bois joined,
was one of the people from
the Niagara Movement who
met-- went to
this conference,
and he joined the NAACP
upon its founding in 1910,
and serves as its sole
black officer. He was the
director of research and
publicity for the NAACP,
and the editor
of its magazine,
Crisis. And Du Bois would
remain at the NAACP for the
next twenty-five years. He
would have this very vexed
relationship with the
organization. So from its
inception, the NAACP
needs to be understood as,
well, one, essentially a
white organization with Du
Bois as the sole
black officer,
dedicated to the improvement
of quality of black life,
certainly. But the
people running the NAACP,
left progressives, some of
them considered radicals,
were all
political agitators,
but they were agitating
toward an assimilationist
goal. This is why Du Bois
felt so at home with this
sort of
politics. The NAACP,
not to make light of the
commitment of these--these
radical progressive
and Du Bois as well,
agitating
towards assimilation,
believed that with
the proper amount,
type, and style
of agitation,
blacks would eventually
integrate into white
society, economy, and
politics. Now the phrasing
of that is very important,
that blacks would integrate
"into" white
society, economy,
and politics. The process
would not work in reverse.
So just as we can, you
know, get worked up,
perhaps, about Washington's
accommodationist politics
and say, you know, we're
really down for the idea of
Du Bois's radical politics
and assimilationist ideals,
you need to also be aware of
what these assimilationist
ideals were about. Blacks
would integrate into white
society, society
that was civilized,
and that was a descendant
of the height of civilized
culture in the world, and
that's Britain. These are
complicated narratives,
but we can ask really
interesting questions--or
because they're complicated,
we can ask really
interesting questions,
sort of such that when
all is said and done,
with Washington's politics
being open for critique,
is it easier to let the
Niagara Movement's or the
NAACP's politics be free
from critique? There's
plenty of criticism to be
thrown around and lots of
critical questions to ask,
and we'll start asking those
questions in section and in
the weeks to come. Thanks
very much. Have
a great weekend.